[Music]
now a United Nations organized
conference on Afghanistan is being held
here in Dohan the Taliban Administration
which came to power in 2021 has not been
invited to take part the UN considers
Afghanistan its biggest humanitarian
crisis the Taliban designated ambassador
to the UN has issued a statement saying
any meeting without its participation is
unproductive even counterproductive it
has a legitimate right to express its
position and the statement questions how
decisions can be acceptable or
implemented if the Taliban aren't part
of the process finally it says the move
is discriminatory and unjustified it
calls for the issues to be resolved
through a pragmatic approach well let's
bring in Osama binch of Aid she's at the
conference for us here in Doha Osama I
believe you've been talking to various
people there what are you hearing from
different parties
but after a Hiatus of about a year and a
half Doha is finally Milling with
diplomatic presence you've got special
representatives for nearly two dozen
countries here uh talking about
Afghanistan talking about the solutions
for Afghanistan and their different
opinions about Afghanistan as well uh it
is an interesting venue because the
people who are actually in charge of
Afghanistan who said are not here and
the biggest issue that Afghanistan faces
about the rights of women there are no
women Representatives who are either
from Afghanistan or living in Exile the
United Nations says that this is a
conference to bring together the world
opinion so when they talk to the Taliban
and the in the Islamic Emirates of
Afghanistan's government they should
speak with a unanimous voice but it is
interesting I've been speaking to
various special representatives and one
Diplomat told me that they are surprised
at how a laundry list of priorities is
being put together by countries
depending on whether they're Regional
countries whether they're Arab countries
whether they're International play as
their priorities are different about
Afghanistan the unanimous point of view
is that there should be rights for the
people of Afghanistan four million
people Afghanistan a vast majority are
living with desperate levels of poverty
and the United Nations should continue
in some way or form its Aid mission in
Afghanistan Tom West the special
representative for the United States
says this is a positive development all
sides are together we've spoken to the
former U.S Envoy to Afghanistan who
thinks that the Taliban should have been
there and we've also heard from the
Taliban foreign Ministry where it says
that the positive steps that have been
taking place in the last year and a half
with terms to eradication of Narcotics
in terms of how there has been a general
amnesty a sense of corruption free
Afghanistan that the Taliban government
would tell you those are the issues that
the International Community must come
together and talk to the Taliban
government and this is uh the second day
as you said yesterday they came together
to talk about the problems and the
issues that are being phase and today
they're meeting to find out Solutions
and how and if there are any incentives
that they can give to the Taliban so
that they can ease up on their reforms
against government and allow Afghans to
live free lives uh some of them Javed
with the latest from those talks here in
Doha we'll have more from him in a
moment but thanks so much for now thank
you Osama well let's bring in our
diplomatic editor James Bay as he joins
me now here on set James so the Taliban
as we've been saying multiple times
obviously isn't here I believe you were
talking to the U.N Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez on the plane who is
here any insights from him as to why
well the Taliban are not here and the
women of Afghanistan are not here and
that is angered
um representatives of both you heard the
man who in the statement you read at the
beginning that the man who would be the
taliban's ambassador the United Nations
if they were recognized by the
International Community and certainly
Afghan women's groups I've spoken to
they're angry as well the Secretary
General and I was on the plane with him
as he flew from New York here to Dohan
we had a chat on the plane a couple of
Chats on the plane he made it clear that
what the purpose of this meeting is is
not to negotiate with the Taliban is
just to get the International Community
all on the same page because lots of
different countries have been doing
different things lots of different
countries have different capabilities he
believes that if he can get them all
working together with a plan then it's
going to give him so much more leverage
than to deal with the Taliban and he was
in recently good form about this even
though the un's had a great deal of
criticism on this
um partly because at the end of last
week the UN Security Council managed to
get a resolution through finally
condemning the Taliban and their policy
with regard to women and particularly
Banning female Aid workers and and the
female un workers and I think he
believes that gives him a little bit
more power going into this meeting to
get that International Community with
one United view on how to proceed sure
so if the UN wants this United view I
know someone was saying this when he was
talking to different parties at the
talks it does sound like there are some
points of contention though what are
those points of contention when you're
trying to find this unified position
there are definitely real really really
difficult points of contention not just
actually among the International
Community but even among the UN itself
there's a Big Growl going on in the UN
between the political side and the
humanitarian side what to do about their
operations on the ground because most of
their operations have ground to a halt
since the Taliban banned women un
workers from doing their jobs now there
are some in the humanitarian side say
well that's bad that we can't have women
working but we've still got to get the
aid out there we've still got to get the
food we've still got to get the medical
supplies and we should just do it with
men the political side said that sends
an awful message to the Taliban so
there's disagreement within the UN
disagreement the International Community
on on the issue of women the other
issues the Secretary General outlined on
me to me governance he wants to try and
persuade the Taliban to bring other
parties into the government to share
power that has proved impossible so far
but he believes with a United
International Community perhaps they can
do that he's worried about groups
setting up a safe haven in Afghanistan
um he's worried Al-Qaeda isil other
groups reforming in Afghanistan and then
the last issue on his list is one that
we don't talk about as much as we used
to talk about but the Opium fields are
still there in Afghanistan particularly
on the south and east of the country
he's worried about the drugs trade I'm
sure he is I wonder what is the next
step after this so you've tried to find
a unified position the security Council
resolution sounds like that may be
possible what happens after this is
there a conversation with the Taliban
from here on in well certainly the UN
will continue its conversations on the
ground in Kabul uh with the Taliban this
meeting is not going to come up with
International recognition for the
Taliban that was never on the table and
the sexual made it clear to me there's
no way the UN will completely pull out
of Afghanistan but there are going to be
ongoing conversations the UN has to make
a decision by Friday on exactly what to
do with its humanitarian operations on
the ground there's also a big review
being commissioned the former Turkish
Ambassador at the United Nations
guitarist has appointed to run that and
that's the report to the security
Council on the way ahead uh by the end
of the year so a lot of reviews going on
the idea of a talk between high-level
the UN and the Taliban we had the deputy
secretary General in Afghanistan earlier
in the year could we want at some point
see the secretary-general talk to the
Taliban pretty enticing Prospect I think
the UN do not really want to give that
up at this stage they've already sent
the deputy secretary General and they're
not got nothing in return they see that
as one of their few bits of Leverage of
meeting between the Secretary General
and uh the Taliban the Taliban would
have to give something to get a reward
like that because that would be seen as
a step towards recognition I don't think
that's happening anytime soon I'm sure
so this very much an iterative step in
that conversation our diplomatic hello
James Bays thanks so much for joining us
and giving us some more analysis here
with us in Doha